I've been being statistics my whole life
so I like my chances here Demar Hamlin
was full of confidence and gratitude as
he announced his much anticipated return
to the Gridiron they almost lost me like
I died on national TV in front of the
whole world Millions were watching
January 2nd as the bills faced off
against the Cincinnati Bengals just
minutes into the game's first quarter
Hamlin took a hard hit to the chest
stood up then collapsed seconds later
medical staff resuscitated Hamlin on the
field before he was rushed to the
hospital he didn't wake up for two days
so the diagnosis of pretty much what
happened to me was
basically commodio quartus it's a direct
blow at a specific point in your
heartbeat that causes Cardiac Arrest I
think most experts agree that a
commercial tortoise is not a reason to
exclude someone from playing sports